there's this $105 billion deal that's
been held up by debate between
Republicans and Democrats over border
right so basically it contains $60
billion for ukraine4 billion for Israel
another several billion dollars for
taiwan's defense against China and then
include some border funding and some
border Provisions Republicans want the
Border funding and the Border Provisions
because we can get into the illegal
immigration issue but that's pretty
serious issue and Biden Democrats have
been unwilling to hold that up and that
that seems to me like just from put
aside Republican Democrat seems like
political malpractice meaning there's a
widespread perception in the United
States that the border is a disaster
area Joe Biden wants these things many
Republicans don't want these things if
he caves On the Border stuff he gets all
the things that he wants and he's going
to be able to go back to the moderates
in the country and say I did something
about the Border it seems like such an
obvious win if he caves On the Border
stuff you mean on the Ukraine stuff yes
because then he gets the whole package
me he can he can go back to his own base
and he can say listen guys I wanted to I
wanted to be easy on the border the
Republicans forc me to it but we needed
the Ukraine Aid we needed the Taiwan
right that's you're honestly you're
going to be more educated than me on
this don't like uh or maybe maybe I just
don't know enough I don't like the
principle that when we negotiate things
in the United States there's like 50
million hostages at all points in time
for every single thing like oh boy here
comes the debt ceiling what do the
Republicans want what do the Democrats
want oh boy like here you know we can't
fund our government um but I mean
obviously the the argument is going to
be that if the Ukraine funding doesn't
come in this bill and if Biden and his
administration feel like it's really
important that unil or not unilaterally
but as a single issue it's not going to
pass so um I would say that at this
point and I don't know what the
conversations look like between the bid
Administration and zinsky I would say at
this point that it's probably fair to
start making contingencies on the money
that we give to Ukraine that listen like
this uh conflict has you know waged on
now like now we need to start looking
for potential piece we can't just write
you an unlimited check so I mean if
those strings are attached I'd be okay
with it but the broader question of like
is it okay to make this particular piece
of legislation with all this funding
contingent on uh the Ukrainian funding I
mean that just seems to be the way the
government works now unfortunately